- Nous sommes à Bellingham,
90 000 résidents et une clinique
d'avortement. En 1970, l'Étatmir
aux États-Unis à protéger
le droit à l'avortem
(applaudissements)
Marissa McGrath a organisé
une manifestation de
500 personnes en faveur
de l'avortement, quelques heures
seulement après avoiaiaiaiaiaiat
lever la protection du droitàààs
de l'État de Washington ont
senti leurs valeurs attaquées.
Et le gouverneur de l'Étatdedet
e e e e e pour toutes les femmes
qui auraient besoin de recourir
à un avortement. a a a a a a a s
du vote de la Cour suprême,ttttà
à se préparer à recevoir
les clientes des États voisins
des États qui pourraient
interdire l'avortement.
En tout, plus de la moitié
ieieieieieieieieieieieieieieieie
l'avortement si le jugemente e .
La clinique de Bellingham
cherche déjà de nouveaux
médecins, et le financement
des avortements pour les femmes
venues d'autres États commence
à s'organiser.
À l'hôtel de ville
de Bellingham, une conseillère
municipale craint
particulièrement pour le bien-
être des femmes de couleur,
qui statistiquement sont
celles qui utilisent le plus
les services d'avortement
aux États-Unis. Elle est la
première conseillère municipale
noire élue à Bellingham.
Face à une Cour suprême
majoritairicicicicicicicaine,
le mouvement pro-avortement
craint que d'autres changements
soient à venir.
Marissa McGrath compte
continuer à mobiliser
les militants pour tenter
d'influencer le vote de la Courr
dans les deux prochains mois.
Ici Benoît Ferradini,
Radio-Canada, Bellingham,
dans l'État de Was